el secretario de relaciones exteriores
Marcelo ebrard casaubón anunció que
dejará el cargo de canciller a partir
del próximo lunes 12 de junio para
dedicarse de lleno a la búsqueda de la
candidatura presidencial de su partido
Morena Esta es una de las condiciones
que el canciller había sugerido para
todos aquellos quienes aspiren a esta
candidatura dentro de morena que dejen
el cargo que actualmente Ocupan que se
organicen debates para exponer sus ideas
y que la encuesta que se realizará para
definir al candidato sea amplia
transparente y verificable hasta el
momento es el único de los aspirantes
presidenciales de morena que ha dejado
el cargo y no se prevé que sus
contrincantes hagan lo propio en el
corto plazo la jefa de gobierno Claudia
sheinbaum ha anunciado en distintas
ocasiones que no ve necesidad de
separarse del cargo por ahora en su
oportunidad y también después de lo
anunciado por ebrar el secretario de
gobernación adana Augusto López a través
de su cuenta de Twitter entender pues no
se refirió específicamente al tema pero
dio a entender que un paisano suyo él es
de Tabasco igual que el presidente López
Obrador le ha enseñado que hay que
equilibrar la razón y la pasión y que
los tiempos del señor son los adecuados
serenidad y paciencia lo cual se ha
interpretado como que no va a dejar el
cargo
ebrar casaubón En su mensaje dejó en
claro que no va a renunciar a morena
como se había especulado en algunos
sectores Pues dijo que se siente
orgulloso de pertenecer al movimiento
que ellos denominan la cuarta
transformación y se dijo agradecido con
el presidente de la república por tantos
años de trabajo juntos se espera que el
próximo domingo que haya el Consejo
Nacional de morena se defina ya las
reglas para esta para esta Selección del
candidato presidencial de ese partido